started getting some visitors from every
Universe hello Peter it's been very nice
to come back to something that is
familiar but at the same time completely
new
confused right now 20 years since his
Green Goblin
17 years since my first time as darcok
what was your name again Dr Otto
Octavius seriously what's your actual
name you got another chance to stir some
things up how you like the new new
collection is like the world did me
wrong and now I got this energy I'm
about to go get mine you know I could
take this away from me docot picks up
where he left off what have you done
with my machine he's looking for Revenge
do you want to play games
the goblin believes in a world of losers
and winners power is all that matters
[Music]
It's a Wonderful World to be in we're
having a lot of fun their danger to our
universe we need to send them back looks
like we got competition
I think people are going to be really
surprised they're going to Marvel
[Music]
with the fabric of reality
what's happening it's starting to come
through and I can't stop them
foreign
hi everyone I am Tom Holland you might
recognize me as your friendly
neighborhood Spider-Man and I am here to
tell you that spidey's back for an
all-new Adventure in Spider-Man no way
home I know people say this a lot but I
mean it when I say that you're gonna see
things in this movie that you've never
ever seen before I'm talking about
pumpkin bombs sandstorm
the Multiverse which okay you might have
seen them before but I promise not like
this and not together also Peter Parker
is finally heading off to college and
the word is out so yeah everyone knows
that he is Spider-Man
so throw your fan theories out the
window they're probably not true or are
they get ready to see one of the most
ambitious films we've ever made an
incredible story with lots of heart
laughter high-flying action mind-blowing
effects and some insane villains no way
home is the culmination of the
homecoming Trilogy and the start of a
Multiverse of possibilities
[Music]
Peter Parker
my entire life got screwed up
could you make it so that Mysterio never
revealed my identity you ready
what just happened
well I shot that spell down we started
getting visitors looks like we got
competition from every universe
exclusively in movie theaters December
17th rated PG-13
where are we going I don't know your
house
hello Peter do I know you we started
getting some visitors from every
Universe this is all my fault
we're gonna get through this
we're gonna get through it together
December 17th